so one thought that I have for educators
are running those classes be very clear
to yourself and then to the students
about whether you are running a class
about game design or game programming
project management when we started this
class will very very quickly we're
trying to be as clear as possible to the
students this is a class about project
management you will do all those other
things in the process of this class and
many of you are here for that reason but
that's the that's the important thing
that we want you to understand and it's
important because it gives you clarity
as an educator on how you're going to be
assessing your students well how you're
going to be teaching your students what
you're going to be valuing over the
other the game can be poorly designed
and maybe have bugs but the team clearly
understands how to communicate with each
other while that is a team that should
be awarded for their work right at least
in the version that we teach other
schools meal can are definitely free to
have a different perspective on this it
could be a better quality of code it
could be about the how brave the
students were when it came to design and
you can award it accordingly but you got
to be very very clear both to yourself
and to the students